thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story The Burning problem for
southern Europe a near record-breaking
Heat Wave predicted to get even hotter
in the days to come
[Music]
we see the economic and human impact in
Greece with the fishermen who can't fish
and the tourists hiding from the Heat
also tonight the former Manchester City
Star breaking down in tears in court
after he's found not guilty of rape
earnings by the hour we reveal the MPS
doing the most outside work beyond their
parliamentary jobs
why there may be Justice tonight for the
victims of America's so-called troubled
teen boarding schools
anything but an Ordinary Boy the tears
and Applause for Barnaby Weber one of
the victims of the Nottingham attacks
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
[Music]
good evening Greece and Italy are famous
for their classical history so perhaps
it's no surprise that the experts have
reached into mythology for the names for
what they could be an historic Heat Wave
across southern Europe the weather event
behind this week's temperatures already
at 40 degrees and Beyond is being called
Cerberus after the dog which supposedly
guarded the underworld next week's
increase which meteorologists say could
break the temperature record is now
being named Caron after The Boatman who
was said to transport people there in a
moment we'll explain what partly climate
change plays and why the weather here is
so different right now but first our
climate change and energy correspondent
Hannah Thomas Peter reports from Athens
tourists heading to the ferry outside
Athens escaping a city that's so hot the
Acropolis had to be temporarily closed
everyone now heeding the warnings to be
careful we're trying to be smart and not
be out in during the middle of the day
trying to stay in the shade as much as
possible so a lot of strategic walking
walking next to walls we take lots of
breaks if we need to go back to the
hotel shower change clothes lots of iced
coffees this is true only for Forest
tires further south of the capital
firefighter Nicos lebronos is less
concerned with tourists than he is with
new wildfires that are starting to burn
okay
he and his crew haunted by the deadly
Blazers of 2021 that destroyed homes and
forests the climate was just of these
days
very warm very dry
and I want to to play not to have the
same situation
in Croatia they have not been lucky this
is the aftermath of Ablaze on the
dalmatian Coast a consequence of heat
wind and dry vegetation
beyond the immediate emergency that
often comes with extreme heat there's
another arguably bigger problem and
that's The Economic Consequences when
it's this hot for this long people are
far less productive and those who are
usually outside can struggle to work at
all
at varkisa marina for example the
fishermen are suffering
people have been told to avoid the heat
if they can and it's bad for business
the fish doesn't stand at the Heat
we have it's too late already the people
are not coming to buy the fish and we
have to leave because the heat is too
much even for us in Greece it is a stark
recognition of the impacts of climate
change
now there are only two seasons Dimitri's
forecast says just summer and winter
there is no in between
the temperature has changed and the
change in the atmosphere is very big
a traditional way of life made harder
struggling to adapt as the heat
continues to rise
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News in valkisa
well the heat wave overwhelming southern
Europe has been brewing for many weeks
our science correspondent Thomas Moore
explains why and what the impact could
be
the heat in southern Europe has been
building since mid-april large areas are
now red hot on this chart as
temperatures are widely around 40
degrees and in Sardinia and Sicily they
may even get close to the Continental
record of 48.8 degrees set in 2021 the
heat originates in the Sahara here's the
North African coast and keep an eye on
the dark blob of superheated air that's
10 degrees warmer than normal as it
drifts North to Spain and then East
towards Italy and Greece but if the air
is hot the ground is hotter still this
is data from Europe's Copernicus
satellite showing land surface
temperatures early this week again deep
red represents more extreme heat the
sun-baked slopes of Mount Etna the
volcano on Sicily were already more than
50 degrees at 11 30 in the morning
they'd be even higher In the Heat of the
afternoon ground temperatures really
matter in urban areas they heat up
houses and streets to uncomfortable or
even dangerous levels in rural areas
they raise the risk of wildfires because
the vegetation dries out faster now heat
waves are a normal part of weather but
scientists say they're being
supercharged by global warming when we
have a higher background temperature and
when the oceans are warmer and the land
is warmer as well then it leads to these
increases that just bring it right up
and start breaking records and and those
temperatures are so high that they
really are in inhospitable for humans
meteorologists have named The Heat Wave
Cerberus after the three-headed Hound of
Hell in Greek mythology next week the
temperatures dialed up further with the
new name of Caron to underline the
thread he was the pheromone of the Dead
the high pressure Zone that brings such
sweltering conditions to the
Mediterranean has to be balanced by low
pressure somewhere else unfortunately
right now that's the UK and Ireland this
weather system is going to bring
unseasonably wet and windy condition
this weekend while the med sizzles were
soaked
the former Manchester City footballer
Benjamin Mendy just wants to rebuild his
life his lawyer said today after he was
found not guilty of charges of rape and
attempted rape the 28 year old broke
down in tears when the verdicts were
delivered a warning that intermember
rasheed's report does contain some flash
photography
with tears in his eyes footballer
Benjamin Mendy walks free cleared of
rape and the attempted rape of two women
Benjamin Mendy would like with lotank
the members of the jury for focusing on
the evidence in this trial
rather than on the rumor and innuendo
that have followed this case
from the outset
Mr Mendy has tried to remain strong but
the process has inevitably had a serious
impact on him that serious impact was
all too evident as he left court the
former Premier League Star had little to
say except this
praise be to God
when Benjamin Mendy signed with
Manchester City in 2017 he became the
world's most expensive Defender but with
it came wealth and Status alongside a
privileged and monied celebrity
lifestyle which led to parties and
Gatherings at his multi-million pound
Cheshire mansion it was here where a
number of women claimed Mendy sexually
attacked them including allegations of
rape after being acquitted in January of
seven rapes and one sexual assault this
retrial on two counts meant a wealth of
evidence was replayed to a new jury
police footage showing an internal
locking mechanism on the doors which
Mendy said was there to protect him from
Intruders and one of his accusers
claiming he said to her it's fine I've
slept with ten thousand women which he
denied saying all along Benjamin Mendy
said everything that happened was
consensual
just earlier this summer his contract
here at the Etihad expired and so for
this 28 year old eager to get back on
the pitch the question is after all this
can he has been found not guilty so most
people will say he deserves the right to
continue or resurrect his career Mendy's
lawyers said the footballer is delighted
and he now wants to focus on rebuilding
his life he hopes now not guilty of
these serious and potentially damaging
crimes he can continue with just that
into man Rasheed Sky News Chester
whether MP should be able to do second
jobs there's a debate which has been
running for decades now Sky News can
reveal the total number of hours they
work and which MPS make the most per
hour the evidence shows they're
certainly not earning the minimum wage
the average being more than 17 times the
typical workers as our Deputy political
editor Sam Coates reports
politicians do with their time
ban all second jobs for MPS I don't have
any objection to MPS having a an insight
into the outside world second jobs
divide MPS in often anger their voters
you get paid best part of 90 grand a
year should be enough we voted them in
to run this country so that's what they
should do Sky News is Westminster
accounts project has followed the money
through our political system now we
reveal the scale of MP's commitment to
their second jobs
for the first time we can show you the
total of how much time MPS say they
spend on their outside work nearly 89
000 hours that's the total amount of
time all MPS have worked in second jobs
over the course of this Parliament so
three and a half years let's see how it
all breaks down these are the MPS who
commit the most hours to their second
jobs
there's some names in there you might
recognize Sir Jeffrey Cox they've become
notorious for their commitment to
outside work but most have one thing in
common all the names on this list have
second jobs in politics counselors
Mayors members of the Scottish
Parliament double political job in
keeping them very busy
and something else we can show you for
the very first time this is the average
hourly wage of an MP in a second job
233 pounds per hour how does that
compare to the rest of the population
well it's a lot higher the average
hourly wage for an MP in a second job is
over 17 times the average rate for a
member of the UK public and more than 22
times the minimum hourly wage
which MPS are getting the most cash for
the hours they work this leaderboard
shows you that these 20 MPS have the
highest hourly rates in Parliament the
name of the top is no surprise Boris
Johnson now free to spend even more time
earning big bucks away from Westminster
the second name on this list is the
shortest live PM in British history but
that has hardly dented her earnings
power Liz truss her most lucrative work
since leaving number 10 has been a
speech in Taiwan paid at a rate of 20
000 pounds an hour nearly one and a half
thousand times the UK average hourly
wage for her insights into Global
diplomacy and that's part of a very
common pattern MPS who've served in
government dominate this leaderboard 18
of the MPS with the highest hourly
earnings this Parliament have government
experience clearly a very lucrative
addition to any parliamentarian CV
plans for major second job performance
have Frozen in this Parliament is it
just a matter of time until voters force
a change Samco Sky News
foreign
Forest tonight tomorrow we heard Sam say
there that reformed two second jobs
isn't on the immediate Horizon and
there's hostility from some MPS to the
very suggestion
well exactly Jillian and that's what's
really interesting is this investigation
this Westminster accounts investigation
from Sam Kota Sky News Deputy politic
editor has really ruffled some feathers
among some MPS now as he was talking
about this is a really important
database of MPS of their second jobs
what they are doing and how much they're
being paid for it and obviously it
really does expose the amount of money
some of these MPS are being paid whilst
also having to be MPS and having their
own kind of main job for their
constituents now we know this is being
driven by a huge a very small number of
hugely significant famous big names in
politics like Boris Johnson Liz trust
former Prime Ministers like Theresa May
and they earn a huge amount of money on
the international speaking circuit but
this reunites the debate around second
jobs and this report is all about
transparency in politics now earlier on
today one of my colleagues Ali Fortress
Cooper Sky News asked the PM's
spokesperson what he thought of the
report and he was very very clear that
he wanted MPS to be focusing on their
constituents and making sure they did a
fantastic job for their constituents now
earlier on as well on Sky News Steve
Bryan an MP who has been working at
second jobs over this course of the
pilot in about almost 100 000 pounds in
this Parliament he was very very unhappy
with the investigation
okay very quickly I just want to ask you
about our latest Westminster accounts
report looking at second jobs you
yourself have worked almost 500 hours in
this Parliament earning a hundred a
thousand pounds all within the rules of
course but how do you think that plays
in public very briefly
I focus on my constituents I focus on
sharing my select committee and I always
have
um and I think you know you should be
very careful about smearing MPS and
making out that MPS are are not focusing
on their jobs 99.9 of MPS I've met in
Westminster are focused on doing their
job and doing the right thing be very
careful into the ground I bet you are
okay
you see there Steve Ryan really trying
to suggest there that this report is
some attempt to smear MPS but this
report is not about smearing MPS it's
about democracy it's about transparency
and it's about having that debate around
whether MP should still be able to have
second jobs so the debate rumbles on but
for now Tory MPS and MPS in general
remain quite grumpy about the sky news
report shedding light
okay Maureen thank you
the oscar-winning actor Kevin Spacey has
claimed one of the men who has accused
him of a sexual assault is after money
money and then money he was
cross-examined in court today and denies
12 charges relating to four men Matthew
Thompson reports from Southern Crown
Court and a warning there is some flash
photography coming up
it's no Hollywood Boulevard no Walk of
Fame instead Kevin Spacey faced a walk
of a different kind through the rain
into a dreary London courtroom to face a
jury on the stand he was cross-examined
on charges of sexual assault against
four men Each of which he denies accused
of grabbing one man's crotch he replied
I do not accept a single word that comes
out of his mouth asked why the
complainant might be lying Spacey said
money money and then money it should
perhaps come as no surprise that a
Hollywood actor of Kevin Spacey stature
is able to create drama but drama there
was at times the courtroom burst into
laughter at others the judge had to
intervene as exchanges between Mr Spacey
and the prosecution reached Fever Pitch
in one such exchange Spacey denied
touching another man he denied it in
colorful terms to much Amusement in the
gallery yes that's exactly where you did
grab him isn't it the prosecutor said
Spacey looked at the judge and said
really before answering I did not
Mr Spacey was repeatedly asked by the
prosecution whether he used his Fame to
pick up men
I'm sure if I wanted to I could have had
sex all the time he said but I didn't
this lawyer to the Stars told me it was
important that Mr Spacey gave evidence
himself it's always difficult for the
accused whether to take the stand or not
now it was dramatic testimony and we'll
see what effect that that has but he
really needed to come out and explain
these allegations in his own words and
let everyone understand where he was
coming from and all these incidents
otherwise it would be
his word against their word against
silence
for years Kevin Spacey has played to
audiences of millions but now it's an
audience of 12 that counts 12 jurors who
will decide whether he walks away a free
man or in Chains Matthew Thompson Sky
News
earlier this year Sky News reported on
the shocking story of Taylor Goodrich a
17 year old who died while at an
American school for so-called troubled
teens tonight her school in Utah has
been ordered by the authorities to close
down the socialite Paris Hilton was
educated at a similar school she said
she was shaking and so excited at the
news our U.S correspondent Martha
Kellner reports
it was to this boarding school in the
middle of the Utah desert that hundreds
of parents including some from Britain
have sent their children over the past
25 years our goal is to help these
students be Diamond Ranch Academy
claimed to be able to fix so-called
troubled teens those with behavioral
problems it's one of hundreds of similar
controversial facilities across the U.S
last year's 17 year old Taylor Goodridge
died while at the school a Sky News
investigation spoke to employees who
allege she was vomiting repeatedly and
begging for help in the days before she
died but was ignored by staff members
former students also said they suffered
abuse at the school if more people knew
like
still be here
now Diamond Ranch has been ordered to
close down after a state report
concluded their neglect did directly
lead to Taylor's death it offers some
Solace to her grieving father what was
your reaction when you heard that
Diamond Ranch wasn't going to get its
license renewed
hug my kids
and told them that
their sister did it Taylor
he's getting a place shut down that
needed to be shut down
a Utah State Licensing Board report
found severe physical neglect by The
Diamond Ranch assistant medical director
it also noted the deaths of two
additional students at the school
Taylor and autopsy concluded died with
sepsis a severe blood infection her
death was entirely avoidable she had an
infection it easily could have been
treated the fact that she couldn't
receive Medical Care they denied her
medical care I think the action by the
state not to renew that license is
entirely entirely appropriate I'm so
excited we spoke to Paris Hilton about
sexual abuse she say she suffered a
different facility in Utah she welcomed
today's news tweeting I'm shaking I am
so excited to share that Diamond Ranch
Academy is closing the state held this
facility accountable and I'm so happy
they can no longer abuse kids a
children's safe coming here
can I ask can you answer that though
that's the most basic question isn't it
I asked one of the school's directors in
February about the circumstances
surrounding Taylor goodridge's death he
said he would speak to anything and
everything in the fullness of time
today Diamond Ranch didn't respond to
Sky news's request for comment Martha
Kellner Sky News
just stop oil protesters have
interrupted the opening night of the
proms at the Royal Albert Hall in
central London the campaign group says
two people invaded the stage before they
were removed within moments of unfurling
banners in a statement the BBC BBC said
neither the concert nor the broadcast
were disrupted
a man in the U.S has been charged with
murdering three women linked to the
unsolved killings of 11 people which
became the subject of the Netflix film
Lost Girls 49 year old Rex Hermann was
arrested as part of the historical Gilgo
Beach murder case NBC reports he has
denied the charges
Hollywood actors have joined
screenwriters on the picket line
sparking an industry-wide shutdown in a
row about pay speaking to Sky News
earlier succession star Brian Cox warned
a resolution to the dispute may take
some time it's a situation which really
could get very very unpleasant and it
could go on for quite some time I mean
you know they'll they'll they'll they'll
take us to the brink and we will
probably have to go to the bridge so it
may not be solved until really maybe not
until towards the end of the year
now most of us don't need a telling that
we're in the midst of a cost of living
crisis but research released today by
the office for National statistics
reveals where it's hitting hardest young
people renters and people from ethnic
minorities are more likely to be
struggling with one in 20 people saying
they had run out of food shingy marike
reports from Leeds
okay what and so what sort of debts do
you have then
places like this reveal the reality of
Britain's cost of living crisis a debt
advice service in one of Leeds poorest
areas seeing soaring levels of demand
we're easily seeing double
what in the amount of inquiries that we
were getting previously now we can't see
everyone we have a certain capacity
those numbers include people struggling
to pay their debts people lose the
houses we do deal with clients who have
eviction hearings
um eviction orders and we'll assist
clients with that
we will always make sure that a client
is prioritizing that so the roof over
your head is is number one that has to
come first a nearby dewsbury it's a
similar story Adam Wilby began to rely
on this food bank when he was unemployed
you get people looking at you saying why
is he using the food bank what's he done
with these more his money Etc and stuff
and it just makes me embarrassed he
works now but still sometimes has to
return all my utilities council tax my
rent and it just leaves me short then
and stuff with whatever when I get left
I just use it on the shopping and for my
shopping and stuff so so I've got food
to last me and stuff like that I have to
rely on the food bank these growing
pressures highlighted in the latest ons
figures on the cost of living crisis
more than a third of people have been
fighting it hard to afford rent and
mortgage repayments
and one in 20 have run out of food and
been unable to afford to buy more
but both these numbers are far higher
for ethnic minority groups who at higher
levels are struggling to afford housing
and three times as many unable to afford
food
to places like Berman Thompson Leeds
where that ethnic minority divide is
felt it's one of the most Multicultural
areas in the city but also one of the
poorest here like everywhere else in the
country people are feeling the pinch
local councilors here are seeing the
crisis devastate lives or affecting them
too I feel the impacts like everybody
else in in the in my constituency as
well as
um you know around perhaps maybe all
over the country so truly um as what my
colleague Lucas said the government does
need to do more
of the economic forecast Bleak those
challenges were only worsen in
communities like these shingi marike Sky
News leads
it's just over a month since three
people were stabbed to death in
Nottingham in attacks which shocked the
country today one of the victims student
Barnaby Weber was laid to rest his
friends and family paid a fulsome
tribute and also remembered the other
lives lost Rachel Venable's report from
Taunton
[Music]
devastated by grief today they came
together to say goodbye
you were like the final piece in what
seems like an unsolvable puzzle and you
always found a way to make it right
You've Been Gone is like trying to
finish that puzzle without the most
important piece it just doesn't seem to
work and I don't know if it ever will
awesome hundreds of people packed out
Taunton Minster and the streets around
it to pay tribute to 19 year old Barnaby
Weber
he really was like a brother to me
Julian
he really
told me everything I know I want to
remind everyone the message that he's
left us with
that we need to live life to our fullest
and be happy every single day and
cherish every moment with the people
that we love
also at the funeral was the family of
Grace O'Malley Kumar she was killed with
Barnaby as they walked home from a night
out in Nottingham last month 65 year old
school caretaker Ian Coates was also
killed that night three families now
United in grief our Ordinary Boy was
anything but that his ordinary was in
fact what made him extraordinary
we remain a family of four
it is one of us isn't here right now
because I'd like you to join to join me
I'm giving my beautiful boy one minute's
Round of Applause
thank you
[Applause]
the man accused of murdering Barnaby
Grace and Ian is provisionally due to go
on trial next year but for now the
Family Focus is on celebrating the life
of their son he so clearly lived his
life to the fullest Rachel Venable's Sky
News Taunton
defending Champion Novak Djokovic will
play the world number one Carlos alcaraz
in The Wimbledon Men's final Djokovic
cruised past Yannick Center despite
being penalized a point for letting out
a loud raw during a rally in the second
set of their semi-final
Djokovic has won the last four Wimbledon
Men's titles and will equal Roger
Federer's record of eight if he wins on
Sunday
[Applause]
the world number one Carlos alcaraz
stands in his way alkaraz swept past
Daniel Medvedev in straight sets to
reach the Wimbledon final for the first
time
well that was Guy News at 10 coming up
we'll take a first look at tomorrow's
newspapers in the Press preview
including this story on the front of the
Star as British holiday makers defy the
heat wave to sunbathe in Europe the
headline
blowtorch Brits tonight we're joined by
the guardian columnist Zoe Williams and
the former conservative MP who's now
chief executive of the charity business
in the community Mary McLeod please stay
with us for more
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
Sky News in just a moment the Press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive but first our
top stories red alerts are in place
across much of southern Europe as Spain
Greece and Italy swelter in the grip of
an extreme heat wave
former Manchester City footballer
Benjamin Mendy has been found not guilty
of rape and attempted rape
and Kevin Spacey has claimed one of the
men who has accused him of sexual
assault is after money money and then
money as he gave evidence at his trial
[Music]
you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the guardian
columnist Zoe Williams and the former
conservative MP who's now chief
executive of the charity business in the
community Mary McLeod they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages for you now
with the headline meltdown the male
covers both the impending strikes at
Gatwick Airport and the sweltering
temperatures in Europe
the star refers to Holiday makers
traveling to the continent in the
extreme heat as blowtorch Brits
the express hears that just stop oil
could stage major demonstrations at rush
hour in London on Monday
the eye has an exclusive report on what
it calls the toxic levels of lead in
school drinking water
the mirror carries a pole suggesting the
majority of those surveyed want to see
the BBC newsreader Hugh Edwards back on
television
according to the times the government
could scrap inheritance tax in a bid to
win more votes at the next election
the telegraph has seen a
government-backed guidance that will be
given to parents of children identifying
as transgender
the guardian says there's massive demand
for a new gaming addiction Clinic here
in the UK
and the financial times has a story
about how American banks are
capitalizing on interest rate increases
and reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Zoe Williams and Mary McLeod welcome to
both of you let's start with the star
not something we um often do I have to
say and their headline there blowtorch
Brits I'm talking about
um British holiday makers suffering in
the heat Zoe
it's really really thing because
everybody
else's though British people would
distract most with the heat which is
reasonable because we have least of it
but the truth is
you know British people are incredibly
robust when it comes to being too hot
and then and there's an absolute years
of evidence that will stay in the sun
way longer than any other European
nation so I think it's it's sort of
self-parody this headline it's sort of
we are ridiculous everybody else is
staying indoors we will still be on the
beaches when it's way too hot the
subtext of course is that it's way too
hot because there's an absolute heat
wave in Europe and this is dovetailing
with the climate change stories of last
week that seven of the hottest days on
record happened in one week so you know
they're kind of tabloid determination to
stay positive and jolly in the face of
Trends which are you know leading
inexorably to the the least good
scenario that scientists have been
predicting for some time
it is
quite extraordinary
yes it does seem as if they are sort of
um making light of um what you describe
obviously and it is a very serious story
and Mary there they're saying that uh
Brits are cramming the beaches and
defying the warnings that temperatures
could hit 49
um and and getting burnt to a crisp in
the process
yeah and that sort of heat is horrendous
I mean I've once been in Egypt in just
about 45 degree heat and you couldn't
move and the and so yeah I can well
imagine probably Brits are the the worst
at doing this and staying out no matter
how hot it is but
um I mean I just I'm someone who burns
really easily I'm just so so white
skinned and therefore it's you know the
whole thread of melanoma cancer and and
things that just are you know people
should be covering up they should be
putting SPF
um and they're sorry to be so serious
about it but it really is you know it
threatens life and and so if people can
still enjoy it
um and just be sensible with it and as
everything in a balanced way isn't it
where it's yeah cover-up wear a heart
puts sunscreen on and enjoy it and have
fun but just be reasonable drink lots of
water be hydrated and it's really the
the way to go and and just enjoy it some
sometimes in the shade and you can still
have fun it doesn't need to be on the
beach for so long and but but take a
break but I'm not surprised at this
headline we I think we all know it does
happen yeah so we'll let that famous um
phrase only Mad Dogs and Englishmen go
out in the midday Sun seem to be living
living up to that but you can have just
as much fun in the shade I often do
um let's move on to the the mail and
there they're combining that the stories
are of the the Heat Wave and also the
impending strikes at um Gatwick which is
also going to cause people lots of
problems over the the summer months Zoe
this sort of bugs me about the Daily
Mail I have to say and I don't mean this
in a partisan way obviously I'm from a
paper of a different political
persuasion but this is a completely
neutral observation they do periodically
roll together a number of negative
events which completely
completely free them from having any
editorial stance on those events right
so the Daily Mail is is typically very
very anti-strikes refuses to even engage
with the idea that strikes might have a
legitimate basis in pain conditions
they're very very skeptical about
climate change they tend to refuse to
even engage with the idea that the
climate may be changing as a result of
human activity
um but they they won't obviously when
those things come to crisis they have to
notice because they're still a newspaper
so they write these kind of flap
headlines oh chaos is going to be way
too hot Gatwick is going to be disrupted
even if you escape the Gatwick
disruption on the way out you you you're
not going to escape it on the way back
in this is all in chaos but because they
absolutely refute the kind of systemic
problems underneath those situations it
just sounds like they sound like chicken
licking you know they sound like they're
just running around
announcing disaster
um and that does annoy me I have to
admit married to you
um see anything in in that analysis that
that you agree with but the the male
aren't engaging in in the reasons uh
behind the strike and are just uh you
know doom doom saying
well it's whether you look at the angle
from heat or strikes
um there's important things underneath
it isn't it and and with strikes it's
about you know are people getting paid
uh Fair salary what are the wages and
that they're on what are the conditions
that they get and the benefits that they
get and and you know it's important
employers look at what they're doing and
and make sure they're the best possible
place to work so
um and then it's what naturally can be
afforded in whichever sort of Industry
you're in but you want to treat all your
staff fairly that should be the the
going in position and but when it's
putting it alongside also I mean with
the the heat aspect and sort of climate
change and Zoe mentioned I mean it's
literally you know yeah I mean the
temperatures across
um the whole world are I mean it's a
whole direct consequence of climate
change what else is it and so it's
really important that that everyone
engages with that and comes up with
really innovative ways to address it and
and we do that on a daily basis and I do
with businesses all the time and helping
them Reach Net Zero
um earlier and trying to get them to get
220 40 and 10 years earlier
um and before that's 10 years for the
government goal but but yeah it's a it's
important that we all engage in in this
debate because it's not going to be done
by one person doing something we all
collectively and individually need to do
so much to to drive better outcomes and
get us to that sort of just transition
and and get um climate action happening
uh Zoe the times going into a bit more
um depth and detail about
um the strikes and they they speak to to
the unions and we've got the unite Union
being quoted as saying inevitably um
disruption will be caused two flights
but there it's a more um in-depth piece
I feel like the times is sort of I mean
I know this would be a ridiculous thing
for a newspaper to try and do but I feel
like they're trying to prepare the
ground for some peace to be reached
before that day of the 29th of July
um you know the the the the dates that
are proposed for these strikes are
absolutely Peak going away for some
holidays and if you think about how that
juxtaposes against the cost of living
crisis if you had your holiday that you
probably could only just afford
like completely ruined by airport chaos
that would be socially quite disruptive
um and I feel like I mean I might be
wrong but I think a year ago the times
wouldn't have even engaged with the
Union point of view I feel like they're
engaging with the Union point of view in
order to grow because some kind of
communication between the unions and the
and the bosses because
it's it you know it would be a crying
shame if those strikes went ahead the
summer was ruined for tens even hundreds
of thousands of people and they came to
an agreement later anyway that would be
a real crying shame the times are
reporting that talks overpayer due to
resume next week and they've got this
rather um helpful q a section about
obviously lots of people who'd be
wondering if their their summer holidays
will be ruined and how exactly they'll
be affected Mary
and I'm away next week
um I'm going from Heathrow but there's
often a repercussion on some of these
things and and certainly if there's a
the whether it's different countries in
Europe that are are more affected by
this and uh and I really hope Gatwick
therefore can resolve it because it ends
up being innocent people families often
young ones as well
um having to either get have really
disappointed from our holidays or be
having to wait long time and hours in in
an airport which is in conducive to to
Family Life frankly so I really hope
they can resolve this this is supposed
to be a positive time of year for
families can get together friends and
you know and and just get away and and
have some proper family time and so it's
a it's a real shame that this is
happening right now and I guess it's why
they're doing it just right at those
sort of summer holidays that are
important so yes if they can sit down
and and go through and and really sort
something out it would be a you know a
huge incentive to to people stop
worrying about it as well because
they're just going to worry about it
over the next
um few weeks before as as they approach
their summer holidays and and are
worried about the disruption that might
happen because of this so we've just got
about a minute and talk about this uh
just stop oil story in front of the
express uh reportedly planning massive
protest on Monday to paralyze London
when I was quite interested in the
Express's juxtaposition right because
they're the only paper that didn't lead
on the weather chaos so you've got
basically the whole Suite of the British
and international media leading on a
heat wave which is making our normal way
of life completely untenable you know
you can't go on holiday you can't go to
the Acropolis you can't have a train
strike in Italy because people are
fainting on the platforms you you know
all the things we used to take for
granted about living normally are being
capsized by the temperatures on Mainland
Europe and then the express goes proper
hysterical about the disruption of just
a oil and I think they've misread the
mood I think there are times on a kind
of gray September day when they might be
able to get away with railing against
climate change activists but when you
can see the effects all around you and
the express is going put just stop oil
in prison you know use your new powers
they look ridiculous interesting
analysis there Zoe and Mary for the
moment thank you
coming up
we are going to be looking at various
stories including could you Edwards make
a comeback according to a new poll
that's what the majority of viewers want
we'll discuss that and more next
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Middle East business
reports and these are the top stories
from across the region this week and
British sports work chain JD Sports will
open around 50 shops across the Middle
East as part of an expansion deal signed
by Dubai base GMG the 10-year agreement
between JD Sports and GMG will focus on
pushing the brand into new markets such
as Saudi Arabia the United Arab Emirates
and Egypt JD Sports says has seen strong
growth in Athletic Apparel cells across
the middle east in recent years partly
in response to the covid-19 pandemic
Dubai property prices are rising at
their fastest rates since 2014. that's
according to new data which reflects
just how strong growth remains in a gulf
compared to elsewhere
in the 12 months between June last year
and June this year house prices surged
16.9 percent while average rents
increased by 22.8 percent according to
property consultancy CBRE
the city has enjoyed a strong
post-pandemic rebound attracting wealthy
residents by relaxing visa rules and
continuing to offer tax-free living
turkey could reportedly attract as much
as 8.2 billion pounds in investment from
Gulf Nations including Qatar and Saudi
Arabia is after president erdogan
completes his State visit to the region
next week
Mr erdogan is expected to sign a number
of significant investment deals during
his trip two government officials have
told Reuters news now in the longer term
the foreign funding secured could be
worth as much as 23 billion pounds for
the defense energy and infrastructure
sectors
Iraq has signed a 20 billion pound deal
with French company total energies to
develop four oil gas and renewable
projects the agreement has been delayed
for several years due to objections from
Iraqi politicians
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
s and Mary McLeod let us have a look at
the mirror and this story uh about uh
well mirror readers and saying that
they're in support of you Edwards
um being back on the television screens
in his um his usual role this is a poll
that they've done in which 53 percent of
people said they want to see him back on
the BBC News at 10 if he's cleared by
Bosses of serious wrongdoing Zoe
and look and this story has been really
peculiar all the way through there was a
huge amount of insinuation there was
very little actual fact the sun has
tried to blame its um excesses on other
people misreporting its original report
but actually the problem with its
original report was that it was very
unclear what it was actually accusing
him of
um it was very unclear whether it
thought he had committed a crime it was
very very unclear on who who was who was
speaking who it was acting as mouthpiece
for and I felt really uncomfortable with
it from the very start and really
uncomfortable with the way the BBC kind
of rolled over to the accusation and
didn't react more robustly and say bring
something real to the table or stop
making these kind of insinuations and
and
I I you know I really I really do worry
that
that there's a there's a sort of a kind
of new standard with that with these
tabloid attacks where you don't actually
need to back anything up you just have
to create this huge cloud of doubt and
um unpleasantness and then leave other
people to clear it up so yeah I mean I
would support any innocent man being
back on back in his job and also given
redress for what he's gone through and I
think the BBC should have defended the
whole case more robustly from the start
there's a Mary to the point of how the
BBC Handler to handle the whole
situation
um the the poll done by the mirror found
that 51 said the broadcaster had handled
the situation quite badly or very badly
yes and I think no criminality has been
found by the police although of course
the BBC still have an open internal
investigation into into the case and but
I do think sometimes in these cases we
completely miss the human element in
them and you know we live in this
country where people are innocent until
proven guilty and they have a right to
respond and this has just felt very much
like a Witch Hunt and I think it's not
just sometimes
um for situations like this I've seen
the politicians and others where
literally the meteor just out to get a
good story and it's and we we do need to
look at it really really carefully
because it takes down the whole of
British Society frankly and yeah I can
understand why people in this pool are
saying yeah we'd support an innocent
person getting back into their their old
role of their phone not to be guilty
um of of anything and but it's important
for any organization and this is where
that's where how the BBC have handled
that and you know you do have a duty of
care to anyone that is
um a that gives a complaint and also to
your staff in terms of how you deal with
it and things should be dealt with
quickly
um really important to see it through
and make sure it's a fair process but
make sure that it is handled and in the
right way okay and at the same time be
creating that inclusive culture for
everyone within the organization
so we uh just a minute or so I think
just to tell us about uh Delia Smith's
latest um food hit what is it this is an
expression
it's a jam sandwich and you batter it
and deep fry it and I have two things to
say about this idea one is that Delia
Smith is a genius I think sometimes we
forget because there's such a
proliferation of TV chefs and people who
know a thing or two about a thing or two
we forget that Delia Smith would
literally never bring anything to the
table unless it was perfect so you know
there's that and there's also that deep
frying anything is delicious I had a
deep fried
that's not what I thought you were going
to say I thought you were going to say
it sounds disgusting and it's terrible
for your heart
sorry I actually I actually went to the
site of the first deep fried Mars Bar oh
my goodness it was an experience Zoe and
Mary thank you very much we'll see you
in the 11 o'clock hour thank you